file to go and rest welcome back to Evan
this is like a death [ __ ] he wants to
touch my boobies who can touch my
boobies okay that's right then you tell
them some cat person we need to find the
tail for the cat and Jeremy I would
happy to delight what is this material
storehouse what why you shake it stop it
stop stop
there's something on the ground and
wooden fish head with it alright we got
the fish that was easy
someone just germinate from the top
floor what the [ __ ] yay five more help
[ __ ] fire more Hill
all right inside of here alright catfish
man it's put there what he's tripping
our balls you [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
I like what you spit on me the [ __ ]
let's say they're totally white painting
it's not really that totally why it has
a dot on it
don't you dare spit on it I wish aah
the [ __ ] just when you forgotten what
someone else urinated beware of lips ah
all right
the [ __ ]
hungry hello come on ah shut up
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die what what are you
doing I don't like this game [ __ ] off is
a little penis
alright let's go in the golden room
password x times x plus x equals nothing
happens cool
I need a row stretches very so much am i
can tell you saw the liars room alright
okay the only truth speaker we're all
chef it's just so green is lying I guess
what I agree with the one in yella
sharra the one in white speaks the truth
I shut up two steps east and then two
steps
alright let's [ __ ] try that
there's a loose title on your face
Polina Wow I died the night [ __ ] oh well
yeah we said at least so it's fine and
don't walk in spin and [ __ ] sharra
ah alright so I'm just gonna say that
they are all [ __ ] liars
shut up you liar stand in front of the
statue go west three steps then South
one step I shut up everyone has an
answer don't you the one in white lies
because we already know that anyway the
only truth speaker wears green that's
also a lie and I she agree with the one
in yellow
well that means this is the truth
I guess all right stand in front of the
statute go east
forceps then north to south all right
let's try that one two three four one
two
you better one there's a number on the
back of the time for what uh-oh
that does not oh [ __ ]
that's what you get aah step it at all
tapenade you can touch my motor
ya want this huh you are throwing my
sweet potato office you can't have that
[ __ ] okay um wait where was the puzzle
it's over here I add some air okay well
you got this press let's see my math
skills 16 plus 4 is 20
four times four plus four no it's really
what
what am i doing I miss clay
wait the net X is 4 right
you
what the [ __ ] it should be 20 it's
problem and there's an odd one out and
how does that mean maybe we're not done
here
liar but it's stripping with red paint
oh yeah so to get a line you know laughs
oh oh
they killed him I get it sleepy alright
there's an odd one out no
No
there's an odd one out the hose and me I
shed this is difficult
what there's a doll on the ground 18
right so there's different exes okay I
was just thinking math I guess well we
need one more number then
oh they have colors I didn't see that no
yeah the green one is 18 oh okay
so 18 times why wait wait Lib the four
was blue right shut up [ __ ]
[ __ ] puzzles man I'm a genius yeah
okay it's purple wait yeah all right we
need to find the other number can we
walk sideways here I doubt it I just
want to make sure
ah tongue keeps wiggling ah why did I do
that
beware of lips and food I don't have
food
[ __ ] me
I need some [ __ ] roses
I shut there's no water [ __ ]
you're not helping me [ __ ] I don't know
what you son of a [ __ ]
well it's gonna be something about this
painting now ah
you just gotta keep clicking it that's
what I said in the beginning I the nine
oh [ __ ] you I should I got a math and
stuff
yah-ha I'm better than you at math I'm
just kidding I'm not alright an apple on
a tree sculpture obtained it with an
apple what the [ __ ] do I do with this I
don't even want to [ __ ] about how
whatever you guys some come at it oh
maybe then broke shotgun aha alright
let's give them lip some [ __ ] apples
yes take the more than Apple just ain't
got that [ __ ] this is tiny legible now
go through my mouth look that's what she
said yeah what is this what is this uh
uh this game was awesome
haha alright let's give them out again
yeah I'll let you pass now [ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ]
ah I didn't see that [ __ ] coming holy
[ __ ]
ah it's really unique scares I love it
alright breath make sense well then I
just see something how we can go in here
what the hell are you but then you suck
Patton I don't know this word well what
is your deal that's an arrow in your
heart hot ones is that my mom the lady
in red
shut up lady man shut up shut your penis
smoking oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] come on
ah no but [ __ ] you stop oh [ __ ] huh okay
I heard the [ __ ]
uh we're going okay yes [ __ ] you [ __ ]
ha ha ha ah it's gotta be something in
the books wait what happened wanted the
other book what what today though that
was a sound ha ha ha ha fastest song
ever I don't mean to [ __ ] do it
yes gave me that [ __ ] yes eternal
blessing save that [ __ ] okay let's go
over here to pivot
whatever you say girl whatever you say
alright that's not [ __ ] art wake up
[ __ ] take it
ha ha I got your key you stupid [ __ ]
don't spit on me
headless snatcher [ __ ] off I need to go
I need sits head doesn't it
hi I'm stupid nice tits stupid Oh spit
down here if I can tell you that's me
every day
alright I shake our head we gotta find a
head or some [ __ ] like that I don't know
some of the words ah [ __ ]
right there's something over here blue
pedals rent pedal is blood
lady in blue where is lady in blue well
let's go in here
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] stupid ass ah yes oh [ __ ]
this games awesome why haven't I play
this before I love it
all right I gotta end it there but like
babies you enjoyed this guy to come
right today and I'll see you next
episode oh boy I may say awesome red
holy [ __ ] it's on me it's on me so tell
me didn't this way maybe gonna fix it
buddy